which means that today is jobs day
at the white house we're talking about
american innovation american products
american labor
we're talking about the health of our
families and cleaner water
cleaner air and cleaner communities
we're talking about national security
america leading the world and the clean
energy future
it's a future of enormous hope and
opportunity
it's about coming to the moment
to deal with this maximum threat that we
exit where that's now
facing us climate change with a greater
sense of urgency
in my view we've already waited too long
to deal with this climate crisis
we can't wait any longer and we see it
with our own eyes we feel it
we know it in our bones and it's time to
act and i might note parenthetically
if you notice the attitude of the
american people toward
greater impetus on focusing on climate
change and
doing something about it has increased
across the board democrat republican
independent
it's uh that's why i'm signing today an
executive order to supercharge our
administration's ambitious plan
to confront the existential threat of
climate change that is an existential
threat
last year wildfires burned more than 5
000 acres in the west
as no one knows better than the vice
president former senator from california
an area roughly the size of the entire
state of new jersey
more intense and powerful hurricanes and
tropical storms
pummeled states across the gulf coast
and along the east coast
i can testify to that from delaware
historic floods
severe droughts have ravaged the midwest
more americans see and feel the
devastation in big cities small
towns coastlines and in farmlands
and red states and in blue states and
the defense department
reported the climate change is a direct
threat
to more than two-thirds of the
military's
operational critical installations
two-thirds
and so this could we could this could
well be on the conservative side
and many climate and health uh
calamities
are colliding all at once it's not just
the pandemic that keeps people inside
it's poor air quality multiple studies
have shown that
air pollution is associated with an
increased risk of death
from covet 19. and just like we need a
unified national response to cover 19
we desperately need a unified national
response
to the climate crisis because there is a
climate crisis
we must keep we must lead global
response
because neither challenge can be met as
secretary kerry has pointed out many
times
by the united states alone we know what
to do
we've just got to do it when we think of
climate change
we think of it this is a case where
conscious inconvenience cross paths
we're dealing with this existential
threat to the planet
and increasing our economic growth and
prosperity
are one and the same when i think of
climate change
i think of the answers to it i think of
jobs
a key plank of our build back better
recovery plan
is building a modern resilient climate
infrastructure
and clean energy future that will create
millions of good paying
union jobs not seven eight ten twelve
dollars an hour but prevailing wage
and benefits you know we can put
millions of americans to work
modernizing our water systems
transportation
our energy infrastructure to withstand
the impacts of extreme climate we've
already reached a point
where we're going to have to live with
what it is now that's going to require a
lot of work all by itself
without it getting any worse we think of
renewable energy
we see american manufacturing american
workers racing to lead the global market
we see
farmers making american agriculture
first in the world to achieve
net zero emissions and gaining new
sources of income in the process
and i want to parenthetically thank the
secretary of agriculture
for helping to put together that program
during the campaign
we see small business and master
electricians designing installing and
innovating energy conserving
technologies
and building homes and buildings and
we're going to reduce electric
consumption and save
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
in energy cost in the process
and when the previous administration
reversed the obama biden vehicle
standard
and picked big oil companies over
american workers
the biden harris administration will not
only bring those standards back
we'll set new ambitious ones that our
workers
are ready to meet we see these workers
building new
buildings installing 500 000
new electric vehicle charging stations
across the country as we modernize
our highway system to adapt to the
changes that have already taken place
we see american consumers switching to
electric vehicles through
rebates and incentives and the residents
of our cities and towns
breathing cleaner air and fewer kids
living with asthma
and dying from it and not only that
the federal government owns and
maintains an enormous fleet of vehicles
as you all know
with today's executive order combined
with
the buy american executive order i
signed on monday
we're going to harness the purchasing
power of the federal government
to buy clean zero-emission vehicles that
are made and sourced by union workers
right here in america
with everything i just mentioned this
will mean one
million new jobs in the american
automobile industry one million
and we'll do another thing we'll take
steps towards my goal of achieving 100
carbon pollution free electric sector by
2035 transforming the american electric
sector to produce power without
carbon pollution will be a tremendous
spur to job creation and economic
competitiveness
in the 21st century not to mention the
benefits of our health and to our
environment
already 84
of all new electric capacity planned to
come
onto the electric grid this year is
clean energy
clean energy why because it's affordable
because it's clean because in many cases
it's cheaper
and it's where we're keeping up they're
keeping up
we're going to need scientists and
national labs land grant universities
historical black colleges universities
to innovate the technologies needed to
generate store and transmit clean
electric
clean electricity across distances and
battery technology and a whole range of
other things
we need engineers to design them and
workers to manufacture them
we need iron workers and welders to
install them
technologies they invent design and
build
will ultimately ultimately become
cheaper than any other kind of energy
helping us dramatically expand our
economy and create more jobs
with a cleaner cleaner environment and
will become the world's largest exporter
of those technologies creating even more
jobs
you know we're also going to build 1.5
million new energy efficient homes and
public housing units
that are going to benefit communities
three times over
one by alleviating a formal affordable
housing crisis
two by increasing energy efficiency and
three by reducing
the ratio wealth gap linked to home
ownership
we're also going to create more than a
quarter million jobs
to do things like plug the millions of
abandoned
oil and gas wells that pose an ongoing
threat to the health and safety of our
communities
they're abandoned wells they're open now
and we're going to put people to work
they're not going to lose jobs in these
areas going to
create jobs they're going to get
prevailing wage to
cap those over a million wells these
aren't pie in the sky dreams
these are concrete actionable solutions
and we know how to do this the obama
biden administration
reduce the auto industry or rescue the
auto industry
and help them retool we need
solar energy cost competitive with
traditional energy
weatherizing more we we made it cost
competitive
weatherizing more than a million homes
the recovery act of our administered
lasting minister ardman the democratic
administration
made record clean energy investments 90
billion dollars
the president asked me to make sure how
that money was spent
on everything from smart grid systems to
clean energy manufacturing
now the biden harris administration is
going to do it again
and go beyond the executive order i'll
be signing
establishes the white house office of
domestic climate
policy and i'll be led by one of
america's most distinguished climate
leaders
former epa director gina mccarthy as the
head of the new office
and my national climate advisor gina
will chair the national climate task
force
made up of many members of our cabinet
to deliver a whole of government
approach
to the climate crisis this is not it's
not
time for small measures we need to be
bold
so let me be clear that includes helping
revitalize
the economies of coal oil and gas and
power plant communities
we have to start by creating new good
paying jobs capping those abandoned
wells reclaiming mines
turning old brownfield sites into new
hubs of economic growth creating new
good
paying jobs in those communities where
those workers live because they helped
build this country
we're never going to get the men and
women who dug the coal and built the
nation
we're going to do right by them make
sure they have opportunities to keep
building the nation in their own
communities
and getting paid well for it while the
whole of government approach is
necessary though it's not sufficient
we're going to work with mayors and
governors and tribal leaders and
business leaders
who are stepping up and the young people
organizing and leading the way
my message to those young people is you
have you're
the full capacity and power of the
federal government your government's
going to work with you
now today's executive order also directs
the secretary of the interior
to stop issuing new oil and gas leases
on public lands
and offshore enough in offshore waters
wherever possible
we're going to review and reset the oil
and gas leasing program
like the previous administration we'll
start to properly manage
unlike it we're going to start to
properly manage lands and
waterways in ways that allow us to
protect preserve
them with the full value that they
provide for us for future generations
let me be clear and i know as always
comes up
we're not going to ban fracking we'll
protect
jobs and grow jobs including through
stronger standards like controls from
methane leaks
and union workers and willing to install
the changes
unlike previous administrations i don't
think the federal government should give
handouts to big oil
to the tune of 40 billion dollars in
fossil fuel subsidies
and i'm going to be going to the
congress asking them to eliminate those
subsidies
we're going to take money and invest in
clean energy jobs in america
millions of jobs in wind solar and
carbon capture
in fact today's action is going to help
us increase renewable energy production
from offshore wind and meet our
obligation
to be good stewards of our public lands
it establishes a new
modern-day civilian climate corps
that i call for when i was campaigning
to heal our public lands and make us
less vulnerable to wildfires and floods
look this executive order i'm signing
today also makes it official
that climate change will be the center
of our national security and foreign
policy
as secretary kerry as our special
presidential envoy for climate
with him the world knows how serious i
am about one of america's
by appointing one of america's most
distinguished statesmen
and one of my closest friends speaking
for america on one of the most pressing
threats of our time john was
instrumental in negotiating the paris
climate agreement
that we started that we rejoined this
administration rejoined on day one as i
promised
and today's executive order will help
strengthen that commitment by working
with other nations
to support the most vulnerable to the
impact of climate change
and to increase our collective
resilience
that includes a summit of world leaders
that i'll convene to address this
climate crisis
on earth day this year in order to
establish a new effort to integrate the
security implications of climate change
as part of our national security risk
assessment
and analysis will also be included
with this executive order environmental
justice will be at the center
of all we do addressing the
disproportionate
health and environmental and economic
impacts on communities of color
so-called fence line communities
especially those communities brown black
native american poor whites it's hard
the hard-hit areas
like cancer alley louisiana cancer alley
in louisiana
or the route 9 carter in the state of
delaware
that's why we're going to work to make
sure that they receive 40 percent of the
benefits
of key federal investments in clean
energy clean water
and wastewater infrastructure lifting up
these communities makes us all
stronger as a nation and increases the
health of everybody
finally as with our fight against covert
19
we will listen to the science and
protect the integrity of our federal
response
to the climate crisis earlier this month
i nominated dr
eric lander a brilliant scientist
who is here today to be the director of
the office of science and technology
i also nominated another brilliant
scientist dr
francis arnold and dr maria zuber
to co-chair the president's council of
advisors on science and technology
so-called pcast
that president eisenhower started six
weeks after the launch of sputnik
it's a team of america's top scientists
charged with asking the most american of
questions
what next what's the next big
breakthrough
and then helping us make the impossible
possible
today i'm signing a presidential
memorandum
making it clear that we will protect our
world-class scientists
from political interference and ensure
they can think
research and speak freely and directly
to me the vice president
and the american people
to summarize this executive order it's
about jobs
good paying union jobs it's about
workers building our economy back better
than before
it's a whole government approach to put
climate change at the center of our
domestic
national security and foreign policy
it's advancing conservation revitalizing
communities in
cities and in the fall on the farmlands
and securing environmental justice
our plans are ambitious but we are
america
we're bold we're unwavering in the
pursuit of jobs and innovation
science and discovery we can do this
we must do this and we will do this
i'm now going to sign the executive
order to meet the climate crisis with
american jobs and american ingenuity
and i want to thank you all i'm going to
go over and sign that now
the first order i'm signing is
tackling the climate crisis at home and
abroad
this next one for restoring trust in
government through science and integrity
and evidence-based policymaking
over here
and this last one is the president's
council on advisors on science and
technology established
i thank you all for your time sir what
sacrifices are you asking americans to
make
sure still support the patient process